public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe à l'issue d'un conseil
européen des 27 consacré au feuilleton
du brésil est mais aussi aux relations
avec les pays tiers nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui le grec
en charge entre autres des migrations et
de sujets qui vous intéressent beaucoup
dans l'exécutif bruxellois margaritis
skinn as bonjour ce poste de co beaufort
ce poste de commissaire vice présidence
est l'aboutissement d'une carrière
entièrement dévolue à l'europe depuis 30
ans nous avait été auparavant le porte
parole en chef de jean claude juncker
l'ancien patron de la commission
vous avez été eurodéputés pendant deux
ans suite à la démission de l'un de vos
compatriotes vous êtes membre du parti
conservateur grec nouvelle démocratie le
parti au pouvoir qui vous a désigné donc
pour travailler dans l'équipe deux ours
ou la fin des relayeurs votre
portefeuille la promotion du mode de vie
européen va du dossier de la migration à
la santé en passant par le sort de la
jeunesse alors précisément cette
jeunesse elle est accusée en quelque
sorte de propager le coronavirus en
faisant des fêtes est en pleine deuxième
vague elle subit des mesures très
strictes comme le couvre feu
installé dans certaines villes en france
elle souffre donc sur le plan économique
universitaire on est en train de
fabriquer une génération perdue
non pas du tout l'europe se trouve dans
une situation exceptionnelle
mais nous sommes dans une dans un cadre
beaucoup plus
de coordonnées que c'était le cas au
début de la pandémie
nous travaillons tous ensemble nous
centralisons les efforts pour acheter
les vaccins quand le vaccin sera
disponible
nous travaillons avec nos états membres
sur les frontières sur les protection
sanitaire sur la coordination nécessaire
c'est vrai que l'europe doit faire un
effort supplémentaire et c'est vrai que
la jeunesse c'est la partie de la
population européenne qui est plus
touchés mais il faut pas entrer dans ce
jeu d'accusation on a pris des décisions
importantes pendant cette période
difficile
le conseil européen des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement ont pris aussi des
accords historiques avec le fonds de
relance au mois de juillet l'union
européenne a démontré que peut toujours
continuer à travailler même dans ces
conditions très très difficile alors
précisément avec la nouvelle vague
pandémique
le plan de relance vous l'avez dit
historique à 750 milliards d'euros est
ce que il est menacée surtout la relance
plus plus généralement est elle menacée
écoutez l'europe se trouve sous un choc
symétrique saint août concerne tous tous
les états membres sont concernés par une
récession sans précédent
alors c'est ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant c'est commencer tous ensemble
de bâtir les conditions pour cette
relance européenne le le centre de
gravité le point d'ancrage de ce nouveau
départ c'est le nouveau fonds de lens
qu'on a adopté au mois de juillet passé
qui offrait le cadre et les ressources
pour le faire on parle de financement
sans précédent qui ciblent le la
nouvelle économie la transition
écologique la transition vers le digital
les
les compétences de gênes les réformes
dans le marché du travail
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour relancer
l'économie européenne le lien entre le
versement des aides et le respect de
l'état de droit c'est une condition
auquel les bons élèves de l'union
européenne sont très attachés et puis
c'est une condition qui est rejeté par
la hongrie par la pologne
comment comptez-vous surmonter ce
blocage je suis confiant qu'on va
surmonter ce blocage pour une raison
très simple
l'accord historique du mois de juillet
passé c'était un accord unanime de tous
nos chefs d'état et de gouvernement
alors je je pense pas que ça soit
logique de ne pas traduire en action un
accord unanime
parce qu'on peut pas réouvrir des
questions des thèmes qui ont été réglés
il y a il y a deux mois et sur le tas du
droit qui est une considération
importante parce que nous devons avoir
la certitude que ces financements dans
tout le pays de l'union européenne
seront mises en oeuvre de façon
transparente efficace et je pense qu'à
la fin les discussions quand qui sont en
cours vont aboutir à une solution
opérationnelle qui pour un qui nous
permettra de traduire en action les
décisions historiques du mois de juillet
alors vous êtes vice président de la
commission européenne en charge des
migrations et vous avez d'ailleurs
proposé le fameux acte migratoire tant
attendu qui est un autre sujet de
blocage pour de ces deux mêmes pays
pologne et hongrie il refuse d'assumer
la prise en charge même financière des
migrants vous pensiez réussir en
renonçant justement à cette répartition
par quota de migrants je pense que cette
fois nous avons plus de chance pour
aboutir parce que nous avons bâti un
une proposition qui combine les éléments
de responsabilité comme le contrôle des
frontières
les relations avec le pays tiers pour
maîtriser un peu le flux migratoires
avec la dimension de solidarité qui
permet aux états de la première
réception de partager le le fardeau ou
les responsabilités d'accueil avec leurs
partenaires
cette proposition qui est sur la table
combinent bien ce deux éléments
responsabilité solidarité et avec nos
contacts et messieurs on a un peu le
sentiment que cette fois l'europe a une
chance d'aboutir alors s'occuper aussi
des flux migratoires c'était le but du
partenariat que l'union européenne
cherche à a passé avec l'afrique un
partenariat économique mais on n'arrive
même pas à organiser un sommet union
européenne afrique
le sujet a été au menu des discussions
du sommet des 27 est ce que la peau des
mines est pas en train de tuer dans
l'oeuf toutes les actions prises pour
endiguer la migration
non je pense pas effectivement le sommet
avec l'afrique a été annulée à cause de
la de la pâte demi et du fait que c'est
très difficile de faire venir de
dizaines de leaders africains c'est les
conditions ne le permettront pas mais
cela veut pas dire que notre intérêt de
construire des relations de confiance
avec les pays africains et tous les pays
d'origine de transit de flux migratoires
deviens pas prioritaire reste
prioritaire et dans notre proposition
pour le nouveau pack de migration c'est
très clair que le volet externe de la
politique d'amiga sion sera une de nos
priorités centrale il faut aboutir à de
deux accords de partenariat avec ce pays
il faut offrir plus de responsabilités
aux jeunes de ce pays de faire une
meilleure vie chez eux au lieu de se
mettre dans les mains
de trafic à la méditerranée alors votre
pays la grèce a subi un terrible
incendie dans le camp de moria sur l'île
de lesbos
il ya quelques mois aujourd'hui 8400
migrants ont retrouvé un nouveau camp
qui a été érigée quand même à lattes ce
sont des tentes
il y a tout de même des conditions
sanitaires encore extrêmement pénible
beaucoup de ces huit mille quatre cents
migrants vivent sans eau
le gouvernement conservateur et à ce
propos sous le feu de la critique vous
trouvez que c'est justifié
hall est fausse il y avait il ya cinq
mois
vingt-sept mille migrants et réfugiés au
moment de l' incendie il y avait il en
avait 12 milles ça veut dire que la
politique de national de migration a
réussi à abaisser un peu la pression
dans l'île l incendie s'était in
incendie organisé par quelques éléments
radicaux qui ont voulu justement que des
conditions de chantage pour les pauvres
migrants qui étaient là et d'ailleurs
ces éléments radicaux ont été identifiés
et ils sont maintenant en procédure
judiciaire
cela étant dit je suis d'accord avec
vous qu'il faut aider à améliorer la
situation dans ces câbles de cales atp
qui cette solution provisoire est
d'ailleurs la commission européenne a
créé des structures un task force pour
intensifier l'aide aux autorités
grecques de mieux organiser subséquents
transitoire mais on a aussi accepté de
nous engager avec les autorités
helléniques dans la construction de
nouveaux camps plus moderne plus
européenne et d'être beaucoup plus
impliqué dans la gestion de ce nouveau
conte qui va remplacer la structure
provisoire mais écoutez il faut avouer
que tout ça ne sera pas la solution
définitive la solution définitive sur le
moment où l'europe aura une politique
holistique de de migration et de l'asile
cela qui va nous permettre mettre la fin
définitivement dans ces situations qui
font pas l'honneur à l'europe alors le
break site qui se profile aura des
conséquences aussi sur les flux
migratoires des sans papiers qui vont
vers le royaume uni alors londres
envisage d'avoir à des recours à des
filets pour stopper les moteurs des
embarcations de migrants
il faut savoir que le nombre de
personnes traversant la manche sur de
petites embarcations a quadruplé cette
année alors est ce que c'est vrai zonal
si une bonne idée est ce que l'europe a
son mot à dire sur la gestion de ces
flux
on n'a pas un système qui commence au
moment de l'entrée d'un fonds à nos
frontières extérieures qui permet
ensuite de deux étapes ultérieures de
contrôle des procédures de solidarité de
contrôle des frontières des retours de
ce qu'ils ont pas droit à rester avec
nous si tout ça qu'il nous faut et je
suis confiant quand je vous disais il ya
quelques minutes que notre proposition
du nouveau pacte va justement permettre
à décès toutes les pathologies des
corrigés tous ces problèmes que nous
voyons aujourd'hui de l'île de lesbos
jusqu'aux os à la manche palais
justement toujours exit les relations se
sont encore tendues entre londres et
bruxelles alors que les vingt-sept ont
décidé au dernier sommet européen de
donner une chance aux négociations
encore quinze jours et boris johnson de
son côté a déclaré il faut s'attendre à
un breakbeat sans accord est ce que vous
croyez encore un deal à un accord à
l'arraché
l'union européenne va épuiser toutes les
marges pour obtenir un accord avant la
fin de cette année qui aussi la fin de
la période transitoire
si nos amis britanniques sont disposés à
à partir sans accord c'est à eux deux
donnez les justifications les
explications en futaie hier aussi d'en
assumer les conséquences
c'est une grande chance pour le royaume
uni d'avoir passé la pandémie dont les
marchés hier précisément parce qu'ils la
période transitoire s'applique encore si
le royaume uni sort de l'union
européenne sans un accord et devient une
espèce de que ces joies d'une grande
albanie à nos frontières
tout sera différent et les explications
qui selon du selon des explications que
le gouvernement britannique devra donner
au citoyen britannique s'est pas l'union
européenne de le faire nous nous restons
une union de nations unies s'ouvre un
ensemble dans un marché qui est un des
plus grands et mieux régulé du monde
nous sommes confiants que nous pouvons
tous ensemble mieux gérer le risque de
la pandémie et la récession alors je
veux pas dramatiser la situation mais je
répète l'union européenne fera tout pour
est d'accord mais si le britannique ne
sont pas prêts pour l'avoir bear un pays
alors en réponse en riposte à
l'empoisonnement de l'opposant russe n'a
vanille avec une arme chimique interdite
les vingt-sept ont décidé de sanctions
assez symbolique contre six membres de
l'administration présidentielle russe et
d'un homme d'affaires influent auprès du
président poutine
les européens semblaient toujours
partagés sur leur stratégie à l'égard de
moscou l'union européenne et composait
devant cette dent membres qui ont l'air
sur ce bilité différentes dans des
questions différentes dans le domaine
différent surtout en politique
extérieure
comme vous le savez là il n'y a pas
encore une politique commune pour les
affaires étrangères extérieures on a on
a un système d'unanimité qui règne et
qui conditions il n'ya pas de doute le
niveau d'émission de l'union européenne
ceci étant dit moi je suis assez content
je dirais même fier que dans même sous
les conditions difficiles nos états
membres toujours ils réussissent avoir
un consensus sur la nécessité de prendre
des décisions qui montrent que l'europe
occupe un centre important de valeurs de
démocratie qu'on n'accepte pas
facilement des tactiques autoritaires ou
deux attentats aux dissidents comme
celle ci alors ok c'est pas toujours
facile à se mettre d'accord et souvent
on se met d'accord aux eaux dénominateur
minimum mais le fait que l'europe peut
encore prendre de décision sur ce
domaine difficile dit beaucoup en faveur
de l'europe sur la turquie
lesieu ce qui menace qui continue à
narguer les européens en méditerranée
avec l'envoi de navires d'exploration
vous avez l'impression aussi qu'on
arrive à se mettre d'accord et que des
sanctions soient en quelque sorte
inéluctable parce que les négociations
se font pas de bonne foi
écoutez là aussi je pense que il y à un
consensus émergent au sein du conseil
européenne que la turquie représente un
problème menace systémique
ce n'est pas que la question de
l'instabilité de
de la méditerranée orientale ici il y a
un comportement systémique qui commence
à libye qui continue en syrie au cours
distant maintenant on a encore nos
calabar à la méditerranée orientale
les amis turcs doivent décider avec qui
ils veulent être dans ce monde
s'ils veulent être avec nous ou proche
de nous en tant que membre de l'otan un
pays candidat à l'adhésion
ce à un coût il faut un certain
comportement
si par contre il préfère l'iran terranoa
match là c'est un autre choix et je
pense que tôt ou tard nos amis tous que
devront faire ses choix stratégiques et
l'europe agira en fonction de cette
décision
merci à vous margaritis kinase d'avoir
été notre invité aujourd'hui pour plus
d'infos d'ailleurs sur le sujet des
migrations vous pouvez surfer sur le
site d'info migrants info migrants point
net
je vous retrouve dans quelques minutes
au parlement à bruxelles avec ma
consoeur de public sénat pour un débat
l'europe
vaut-elle trump a tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue au parlement de bruxelles où
se réunissent toujours les députés
européens cette semaine vous allez le
constater le regard de l'europe est
naturellement tourné vers l'autre côté
de l'atlantique
à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle américaine du 4 novembre
donal trump a été testé positif aux
convives il est reparti en campagne mais
est-il le président idéal pour les
européens
face à lui le candidat démocrate plus
consensuel joe biden les quatre ans de
présidence de donald trump ont été
jalonnées de bras de fer constant avec
les européens le président américain a
taxé des importations européennes
brutalement il s'est retiré de l'accord
de paris a laissé planer le doute sur
l'utilité de l'otan et mener une
politique extérieure en solo alors quel
est le meilleur locataire de la maison
blanche pour le projet européen pour qui
les européens votre et il s'il était
amené à se prononcer certains ont déjà
choisi leur champion c'est donald trump
pour le ministre premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban et nous avons
aujourd'hui en notre compagnie le chef
de file de son parti le fidèle au
parlement européen ici donc ballast
veggie bonjour vous êtes dans le parti
toujours dans le grand parti populaire
européen qui est d'ailleurs très divisé
sur la question au de donald trump on va
en parler et puis bien face à vous
javier moreno sanchez vous êtes un le
chef de file des socialistes et
démocrates espagnols ici au parlement
et sans surprise bien entendu on envie
de dire vous votez drogba et dunn qui
vous êtes une soutien naturel un des
démocrates pourquoi est il temps de
changer pour joe biden est ce que ce
serait vraiment profitable
alors d'abord je veux dire que les
élections américaines sont passionnantes
est très importante pourquoi parce que
leurs enjeux va beaucoup plus loin que
les frontières des états unis parce
qu'en fait elle nous touche tous et
spécialement les européens problème
c'est que nous on peut pas voter c'est
clair que ce pouvait voter vous l'avais
dit je voterai pour byron et jamal à
arris les il faut de l'étendre le club
se serait profitable à l'europe ce
tandem pour changer complètement la
dynamique et ses quatre dernières
année donald trump a utilisé sa
présidence comme une télé réalité où le
show prime avant tout où l'essai du et
le multilatéralisme où il s'est retiré
des accords de paris il voulait se
retirer de l'eau et metz en fête et il
est en train de le détruire tout ce
qu'on a construit
n'oublions pas que donald trump c'est
pas les états unis les états unis oui
d'accord mais nous pour nous les etats
unis c'est un partenaire essentiel un
allié avec lequel on a travaillé pendant
très très longtemps et avec lequel on
doit continuer à travailler
vous trouvez kelly nous a malmenés
depuis quatre ans donald trump ont voulu
renouveler votre confiance
écoutez donner un truc pour moi c'était
un président courageux qu'ils avaient
résolu à faire sa politique
en même temps il faut distinguer je
pense entre les deux choses il faut
distinguer entre la rhétorique et le
style
à l'exemple de son goût de sa
communication est le fond et le contenu
de sa politique en ce qui concerne en ce
qui concerne par exemple les liens
commerciaux entre les états-unis et
l'union européen nous avons signé une
déclaration il y a deux ans le président
jonckheere dans cette époque-là de la
commission européen et président 30
indique cette déclaration concernant le
commerce après il y avait merci à
négocier au final il y a un truc qu'il y
avait des progrès il ya un an
en 2019 la commission européenne afin en
une analyse qui était plutôt positive
donc il ya des progrès aussi jonathan
prédit que america first
donc il faut il faut défendre il faut
protéger l'entrée national de son propre
et ça c'est juste d'accord avec ça c'est
la même chose pour l'europe
pour nous c'est l'europe d'abord donc il
faut trouver un accord entre les deux
c'est beau c'est que les hameaux s'il
arrive
l'ami des tarifs notamment à mon pays au
produit des taxes des taxes du swing
denis faroud par exemple sur le lit
alors ça c'est super comme une relation
de partenariat commercial c'est ce qu'il
faut il faut savoir si on défend nos
intérêts ou les intérêts de monsieur
donald trump
alors j
comment un donald trump 2 renforcer s'il
était réélu est ce qui peut déclencher
une nouvelle guerre commerciale
la guerre commerciale il a déjà
déclenché alors si vous la mener
jusqu'au bout ça on verra c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'il faut vraiment changer
de cap et revenir à ce qui a été la
relation normale et naturelle avec un de
nos poules plus grand allié je vais
parcourir moi histoire sur sur ce qu'il
a joué le rôle que les états unis ont
joué pour l'europe mais il faut qu'on
revienne à ça vous savez dans une guerre
commerciale avec la chine
donc où on se situe là au milieu
ok mais on peut pas critiquer le
président américain pour représenter son
propre entrée américain au commerce
il faut trouver une solution pour nous
revient aussi convenable les jeunes
américains ou européens
nous vous ils nous marquent ou bien
d'abord bien sûr pour nous c'est
l'europe d'abord alors mais on parle à
propos de monsieur femme alors
l'organisation mondiale du commerce a
autorisé mardi dernier l'union
européenne à surtaxer pour 3,4 milliards
d'euros les importations américaines
après avoir accordé d'ailleurs la même
motorisation il ya un an et 30
d'ailleurs pour le double de d'argent
pour vous est ce qu'il n'est pas
désormais temps aux européens vraiment
d'adopter ces fameuses sanctions
financières et de surtaxer pour se
défendre les produits nécessaires oui si
nécessaire oui si nécessaire oui
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
sert pour le 1er pays européens
il faut nous ou nous il faut défendre
notre propre entrée envers les
américains et tous les autres mais le
débat entre par exemple les américains
et la chine les etats-unis et la chine
et c'est un débat qui est fait vraiment
là en débat commercia qu'il faut avoir
donc il ne faut pas être il faut il faut
avoir les débats c'est ça le point que
je voudrais faire et et pour l'europe
c'est la même chose pour débattre il
faut être deux et pour le mener tout
seul alors justement ma classe il devenu
votre premier ministre il a toujours un
prôné qu'il fallait des mesures
protectionnistes des aides d'état en
fonction des intérêts de son pays ce
qu'il a appelé la démocratie il libère
et libéral est ce que vous considérez
que c'est aussi le modèle 1 prenez par
donald trump est le seul qui
égouttez les nationaux c'est pas la même
chose donc il faut défendre bien sûr les
entrées nationales pour nous en europe
il faut respecter les états membres de
l'union européen donc on peut être un
patriote et en même temps européen c'est
ça la hongrie nous sont patriotes ont
gras et nous défendons bien sûr l'entrée
en gras mais nous sommes fiers membres
de l'union européen et nous voudrons par
exemple que l'europe doit faire plus en
sécurité par exemple et à la coopération
militaire par exemple
en même temps on nous voulons aussi par
exemple je le fais plus vous arrêter la
migration illégale
cet emploi par exemple d'accord avec la
politique de monsieur trump qui était
toujours contre la migration ya en effet
un continuum idéologique entre le parti
de là bien sûr la démocratie libérale
c'est pas un concept qui correspond à
nos valeurs et aux principes de l'union
européenne donc déjà là une
contradiction de départ démocratie
libérale il faudra qu'on m'explique
comment ça correspond aux valeurs qu'on
est fort au sein des 27 pays membres de
l'union européenne de venir le ps qui a
été dit sur les valeurs chrétiennes
démocrates
la définition libéral de gauche de la
démocratie ce n'est pas la seule façon
la seule possibilité il y à une
démocratie chrétienne démocrate
traditionnistes c'est ça notre point de
vue et c'est pas du tout qu au contraire
leur vaut pour la fondation de l'énergie
concernant la la les valeur comme vous
dites démocrate
d'abord je pense que vous devez débattra
au sein de votre de votre parti parce
que je pense que nous sommes en train de
le faire et démence est indiqué en tenue
justement débattent et je pense que vous
n'êtes pas tous d'accord sur les valeurs
des deux ne va changer va changer
justement sera menée une relation plus
équilibrée dans le commerce de confiance
avec les européens ou est-ce que c'est
trop tard déjà mais c'est ce qui a
existé ce qui a existé
la parenthèse trump j'espère qu'elle va
se refermer
parce que le partenariat qu'on a eues
avec les états unis doit revenir à ce
qu'il a été pendant des décennies et
beaucoup de beaucoup d'années là on est
arrivé dans un monde surréaliste parce
que même avec des d'autres présidents
républicains on a réussi à maintenir
cette relation mais là ils veulent à
couper complètement
il le démontre par par toutes ces
attitudes et par sa politique de tweets
est de deux têtes de télé réalité en
fait avec la pologne en est d'autres
pays de l'est vous êtes particulièrement
sensible en au parapluie militaire
américain des troupes américaines ont
pourtant été aurait tiré d'europe sous
le premier mandat trump est ce que il ne
risquerait pas de ce que les américains
ne risquerait pas de se désinvestir
encore plus de l'alliance atlantique
s'il y avait un second est ce que vous
craignez cela parce qu'il faut que nous
européens que nous en fassions plus il
faut que nous nous fassions ne vous
oblige oblige l'europe en faire plus sur
le terrain mais l'élite et s'assécher je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça je me
souviens quand j'étais dans un an ni
vente dans le cadre dans les années 90
la guerre de yougoslavie qui a duré
pendant des années c'était terrible ici
juste à côté de nous et l'europe dans
cet apport à la communauté européens au
lieu en europe et 1 ne pouvait pas faire
rien de tout les années passent passé et
ça continuez continuez finalement cédé
américain bill clinton à cette époque là
qui ont fait l'intervention et arrêter
la guerre donc l'europe doit être
capable de faire les choses comme ça
doit être capable de arrêté par exemple
vous êtes geek avec avec les poussins
u10 dont une en lui disant longtemps
peut-être il est temps qu'on s'émancipe
non non non je pense je pense que
effectivement d'avancé sur le plan de la
défense européenne ça on est
complètement d'accord mais ce n'est pas
monsieur donald trump qui doit nous dire
comme on doit le faire
d'accord donc c'est clair et moi j'ai
toujours prôné effectivement pour une
défense européenne beaucoup plus
puissante dans le cadre de l'otan c'est
une alliance qui tient depuis depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et c'est un cadre qui pour le moment a
maintenu la peine je le regarde de
l'autre il faut travailler là dessus il
essaiera monsieur donald trump qui doit
venir nous expliquer comme on doit le
faire
ou pas le faire écoutez en ce qui
concerne l'otan je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec ou c'est pas question
mais il faut faire plus donc dans l'otan
il faut payer plus il faut faire les
investissements financièrement pour
chaque pays en dotant et ça c'est le
point de transférer par exemple c'est
pas contre l'otan c'est pour un acquis
vivre un petit peu plus encore faut-il
se mettre d'accord car sur de très
nombreux sujets en israël l'iran la
libye donald trump
il l'a joué totalement solo faisant fi
de l'avis des européens ça vous convient
cette politique écoutez je pense que ça
c'est une percée par exemple un proche
orient que de nouveaux pays
le bahreïn et les émirats ont fini un
mot enfin la commission de l'israël
l'acceptation d'israël
ça c'est une chose très important au
prochain tour show lyon attend la
diplomatie vous êtes d'accord maintenant
écouter on avait atteint quand même
quelque chose avec beaucoup de travail
et notamment la l'union européenne avec
la représentante pdk modèle hmo guérini
on avait atteint un accord nucléaire
avec un sociaux sur le nucléaire avec
l'iran et monsieur le trompe il arrive
et met le feu à la poudrière donc il
faut arrêter et il faut il faut remettre
le multilatéralisme au milieu du débat
et ça peut pas monsieur donald trump qui
va nous donner des leçons là-dessus je
pense que monsieur by day oui on va
revenir à la normalité
parce qu'ils étaient là les relations
normales multilatérale il faut être plus
puissant pour l'europe de faire une
partie de ses confrères à faire plus
puissants il faut à dubaï donne pour
l'europe
de quel point de vue c'est sera mauvais
pour l'europe selon le gouverneur je
suis conservateur et mon parti aussi
donc senna retrouver un monde donald
trump et la partie contre les politiques
conservatrices de la trempe qui qui moi
je trouve mieux pour aussi l'amérique
mais aussi en europe
donald trump a il a toujours été
favorable au brick city l'a promis au
premier ministre et johnson un accord
commercial très favorable qu'il y ait
mon si près des européens
joe biden lui est plus nuancé
trump ou byden cela changerait
clairement la donne sur le divorce sur
le break site
c'était déjà un fait ma mère de sortie
parce qu'il ya encore des négociations
quand même un destin je pense va être
entre la grande bretagne et l'union
européen c'est pas les états unis ça
fait pas différence blondy france à mon
avis un train pour baden vous pensez que
ça peut changer quelque chose sur le
mexique le brésil c'est une perte pour
les britanniques et pour l'union
européenne ça je pense que c'est évident
le rôle de rapeller premier plus c'est à
dire leur premier de faire mieux que les
européens ont fait 400 vercia fait
quatre ans qui fait des promesses à tout
le monde et du show donc si c'était
quelqu'un de sérieux peut-être que je
faisais le prendre au sérieux mais c'est
pas quelqu'un de sérieux comme européen
secondes à faire c'est de trouver un
accord et effectivement ok on respecte
le divorce mais il faut trouver des
règles et il faut il faut respecter les
accords mais je reste zen demande à
boris johnson de respecter ce que ne le
fait pas de nature là c'est une
différence une réelle différence
effectivement et je pense que de
nouveaux fonds revenir à la normalité
alors la normalité parlons maintenant
pour terminer que d'une date importante
le 4 novembre
évidemment donald trump remettrait en
cause la validité des résultats de
l'élection présidentielle alors là les
européens doivent réagir comment oui
alors je sais pas si c'est un concept de
la démocratie libérale peut-être ans je
ne sais pas mais un candidat qui annonce
que s'il perd il n'accepte pas c'est
très très dangereux non seulement pour
les états unis
quand même quelle démocratie on dit que
c'est peut-être la plus grande du monde
et tout mais imaginez l'image qu'on
donne au reste du monde
et si les check and balance ne les
pouvoirs et contre-pouvoirs ne
fonctionne pas je sais pas où on va
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors on fait
comme le cachet qu'on reconnaît pas
donald trump comme président des états
unis ça on verra mais j'espère que tout
ça c'est du bluff c'est de la campagne
électorale et que la tradition
américaine
quand même regarder ce qui s'est passé
en 2000 alors je pars revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé mais c'était pas très
claires et al gore a quand même
respecter quelque chose qui à mon avis
est n'était vraiment pas clair écoutez
je pense que donald trump ainsi que
monsieur byden
ils vont accepter les résultats c'est
sûr c'est mon opinion
en même temps on peut avoir un débat par
exemple concernant la votation ici en
europe il ya quelques mois si vous vous
souvenez il y avait de l'action
présidentielle présidentielle en pologne
il y avait un grand débat là bas est ce
qu'on peut et est ce que les polonais
peut vous pouvez vous par utiliser la
votation par lettre et c'est donc c'est
ça le point de débat on est en amérique
est ici en terrain connu
les règles n'ont pas dit non non ça ne
pas utiliser en pologne
hélas ici on peut remercier l'inter aux
états unis les règles sont écrites ils
ont le droit à l'élection anticipée
qu'elle va voir on peut avoir un débat
concernant par exemple comment ça c'est
mais jésus comme la gestion de la
votation effet commencé celle d'un
management revient en 2000 ou avec des
poinçonneurs de il y avait différents il
faut quand même remettre les débats en %
quand même on va pas refaire l'histoire
tout entière ici merci à vous d'être
venu sur ce plate et auto merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis merci à vous tous
vous restez bien sûr sur nos antennes
pour la suite de notre programme
[Musique]